nous avons été rejoint un plateau par
ATIS Barret le jeudi vous nous proposer
une chronique sur les animaux et
aujourd'hui à tisses on va allier
écologie et animaux puisqu'on peut
recycler les sapins de Noël pour les
animaux effectivement Mathilde donc déjà
quel dommage de voir des sapins qui
jonchent le sol alors qu'on pourrait
donner donc c'est sapins à nos amis les
chèvres j'ai ramené pour imaginer un
petit peu quelques petites branches de
sapin j'aime bien imaginer le
pragmatisme donc alors en fait les les
sapins les chèvres sont très friandes de
des épines de sapin il y a à l'intérieur
des vitamines elles pourront faire le
plein de d'oligo-éléments de minéraux
puisque pour l'instant la période est
plate il y a pas assez de vert donc les
les chèvres vont pouvoir prendre une
petite bouffée d'oxygène avec ses épines
de sapin et puis en plus de cela bah
grâce à vous les premiers fromages le
sentiront l'odeur de résineush par
contre à proscrire au niveau des chèvres
qui sont en période de gestation et au
niveau donc des faites vous faites leur
plaisir elles vont manger à Poissy
jusqu'à fin février est-ce qu'il faut et
alors est-ce qu'il y a d'autres objets
que l'on peut recycler pour les animaux
plutôt que de les jeter à this et oui il
y en a vous avez dit objet j'ai d'autres
objets donc je vais vous présenter donc
on peut facilement donc recycler les
caves à vin après les boîtes à vin après
les fêtes donc nous avons bien bu on a
bien reçu
donc j'ai je prends ma petite boîte à
vin qui m'a été donnée donc j'ai pas eu
besoin de chercher loin par mes amis on
peut décaler remercie ma chère Céline
Nathalie Georges qui ont bien vu avec
modération bien sûr alors donc on a ces
petites boîtes en bois donc on va servir
pour faire des abris à Hérisson comme
vous le savez où vous savez peut-être
pas les hérissons sont en voie de
disparition
d'ici 2040 ils sont très importants donc
ils sont protégés par la loi française
ils sont protégés par l'article elle 214
du code tirer un du Code civil de
l'environnement donc j'ai ramené
également de la paille
que je pose que je me permets de poser
allez-y vous avez tout ramener
je vais venir
donc on va donc j'ai pris des feuilles
mortes ce matin vous allez creuser donc
un petit trou de 20 cm d'accord et donc
on y met d'abord un tapis sur le trou de
feuilles mortes
ensuite ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va
mettre notre petite caisse à vin
voilà on va la retourner donc on choisit
un endroit qui est calme à l'abri des
enfants pas de footballeur à côté et
puis on y ajoute de la paille que j'ai
récupéré ce matin de la mini ferme de
Poissy je remercie ma chère Irène et mon
cher Alexis
voilà voilà le
hérisson il est très solitaire il va
hiberner et donc il va reproduire il va
se reproduire et nous faire des familles
de hérissons qui nous protège le
hérisson donc nous protège des
prédateurs il protègent au niveau de la
biodiversité
donc ils vont chasser les escargots et
les limaces qui nous saccagent nos plans
au niveau des jardins nos plans de
salade de tomates et de haricots
pourront faire leurs propres maisonnette
pour
hérisson est-ce que vous avez
le dernier conseil à this oui alors si
vous souhaitez protéger les oiseaux
comment savoir à nouveau froid les
températures montent descendent à partir
de la semaine prochaine il va faire de
nouveau froid et ils vont peut protéger
donc nos amis les oiseaux en mettant des
pommes poires graines de tournesol ou
alors des boules à graisse sur les
rebords de vos fenêtres merci pour en
tous les cas merci beaucoup à tous alors
on vous retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour une nouvelle chronique sur les
animaux exactement vous allez nous
parler de quoi alors c'est de la
prévention pour protéger nos animaux
quand ils sont seuls à la maison et ma
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine